hey guys so the brothers trust okay
thank the amazing support has been
incredible hey awesome stuff like this
go to my Instagram account go on the
link my buyer go on the brothers trust
website and you'll get to come to say
hang out with me and it'll be amazing
and for the record I do all my own
stunts all of my own stunts I never ever
saw it's always me Tom Cruise does a
similar thing I'm the same hey everybody
its charlie we got brand new spider-man
far from home let's break it down we
finally got our first shot of one of the
other new villains if you're new to the
channel there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video uh name
a new winner at the end of this so the
funny thing that's going on here is
they're using Tom Hollands spoiler man
to drop another teaser for the movie and
let you know where they are so that's
why he's mysteriously just what a
coincidence standing right next to all
these t-shirts that say Venice all over
them on this big bridge where he's
telling this funny story about how he
does all of his own stunts like Tom
Cruise while they have this giant blue
screen action scene behind them with his
stunt double getting blasted with water
right off of the bridge with his
web-shooters on but no costume so this
is them confirming yes we're in Venice
were filming everybody heard about the
samuel l.jackson teaser he himself
wanted to get in on the spoiler game
with Tom Holland and Mark Ruffalo
inserted posting pictures of himself all
over Venice and people were like why is
Sam Jackson in Venice he went back to
start filming Nick Fury stuff so if he's
in Venice that must mean that he's in
spider-man far from home so that's why
you saw all those news articles last
week about Marvel confirming Maria Hill
and Nick Fury for spider-man far from
home so they're also in Venice while all
this is happening - and even though you
haven't seen them all of Peters friends
are on this class trip this vacation
that they're on traveling around Europe
so this teaser video doesn't necessarily
confirm that this is hydro-man but the
reason why people think that that's the
villain that he's fighting here is
because he's getting blasted with the
giant jet of water those are Hydra man's
powers and a couple months ago I did a
sinister six video talking about this
but someone saw some concept art
all the different boss battles where he
was fighting people one of them was him
in Venice fighting someone in the canals
this seemed like hydro-man so people are
like okay wow this just seemingly
confirms that but it's not totally
official until you actually see someone
with like a special effects water jet
blasting him in broad daylight
the way they film stuff like this is
they just have like a water cannon off
screen that blasts him in the face like
there's not actually somebody with a
villain costume standing on the other
side of this frame they lie that part in
special effects later on so that's also
the important part too is that you
notice he's not wearing his costume
underneath this like they're just
wearing the shirt with the web-shooters
the suit is probably in his backpack but
he gives you a good idea for why he
needs to upgrade his costume so we know
that he starts out with the homecoming
suit maybe he just gives back the iron
spider costume to Tony Stark at the end
of Avengers 4 but for whatever reason
he's mostly friendly neighborhood
spider-man when they're travelling
around Europe here but the thing is is
that Tony Stark didn't build in a lot of
aquatic features remember when he fell
in the river during spider-man
homecoming Tony Stark had to send Friday
to go fish him out because even though
he had a parachute he didn't have any
kind of life preserver built into the
suit so he woulda just sunk right to the
bottom
so that is why hydro-man is an
interesting villain for him to fight
because he'll have to upgrade his suit
if you haven't seen it a long time the
90s animated spider-man series did a
really good version of hydro man vs.
spider-man so he debuted for the first
time in amazing spider-man number two
one - the comic book story is pretty
much what they did for this animated
show remember when I was expelled from
school after that my parents made me
enlist in the Navy and they said it was
to keep me out of trouble but you were
right to dump me Mary Jane because I I
had nothing I was a nobody even after I
was transferred to special research was
still a loser
last month deep inside the earth changed
me turned me from a nothing into
something
now I had power now I could have
anything in the world I wanted do I get
my merit badge you think you can get out
yet that your web is useless against me
yes so I made this new batch just for
you
[Music]
what did you do it in is he okay
no he's stuck I mixed a powerful
coagulant into my web fluid one that
would react with the h2o in his body and
become a hardening agent what basically
I stirred powdered gelatin into him
let's just say he's getting his just
desserts the really cool thing about
that upgraded webbing is is that we know
already because of homecoming and
because of Civil War he makes all the
webbing by himself with maybe a little
bump from Tony Stark on some of the
materials like I'm sure he's given him
access to some chemicals that helps him
strengthen his webbing sometime between
this and Avengers four but that original
spider-man story took place in New York
City this is happening in Venice but
Venice canals you get the idea there's
water everywhere so spider-man is at a
huge disadvantage until he adapts the
way they defeated him in that original
story is is they weaken his molecules so
that he couldn't bring himself together
by heating him up and dosing him in a
bunch of ashes just making it harder for
him to use his water abilities then
lured him onto a hot roof top where he
slowly evaporated into the air Maury
it's over we've got to get you some help
[Music]
I'll destroy you with my bare bent stone
he's not necessarily h2o is infamous
among solvents for itself cohesiveness
brother now you sound like my friend
Peter Parker hey don't insult me but the
funny thing is is that like later you
see spider-man looking at a cloud hoping
that he somehow found some way to heal
himself or fix his life then sort of the
post-credits scene is the rain falling
on new york city implying that hydro-man
would eventually reform because he's
basically pure water so he evaporates
into the clouds then later a storm helps
him reform his molecules so he becomes a
villain later on - so spider-man doesn't
kill him because spider-man is gonna try
to kill somebody remember disable
instant kill mode
hence combat mode yeah activating
instant kill no no no I don't wanna kill
anybody deactivating instant kill so as
of right now they've only added a couple
more people to the movie still have not
confirmed Jake Gyllenhaal is Mysterio
still supposed to be the main villain of
this movie despite the other four or
five other villains that seem to be in
this I've already done a couple videos
about Mysterio impossible sinister six
even if they don't call it that specific
team during this movie they might just
be building up towards that in the next
big movie I know from a footage
standpoint people are mostly focused on
the Captain Marvel trailer and the
Avengers for first teaser but there's
still a lot of filming left to do on
spider-man far from home and this is
probably the most fun way for them to
market the film that I've seen so far
because it lets you know what's going on
without being super spoilery like it
gives us enough to go on so just expect
Tom Hollands spoiler man to continue
dropping set videos like this teasing
stuff from behind the scenes for the
next month or two what'll happen next is
is there was a whole bunch of other
stuff that drop recently so I'll try to
get through those videos as fast as
possible congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video 8 in
Borrego please email me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
Hawkeye Ronin in Avengers 4 and click
here to learn all about the different
villains in spider-man far from home
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]